I was going through the drills and he
kept stopping I'm like that's all you
got that's all you got and I'm like bro
I'm going hard as you want me to go like
what you want me to do I'm sweating
crazy he like man you got to see Steph
and KD and Clay work out and um we went
to dinner that night and they would they
still was continuously telling me like
you you didn't work hard enough like if
we had the number one pick we wouldn't
take you and I was just like damn that's
crazy so me and my trainer ran home
after dinner and we just talked like bro
we got to pick it up I don't know how I
don't know what we got to do like but we
got to pick it up and I think after that
man it's just I became a mad man in the
gym and like I just I try to work till
I'm tired I'm exhausted